tu sais parler tout son coeur à part
gilles qui le fait toute la journée les
deux types de pigeons à les emmy awards
à la craie ouais et le pigeon ils
veulent très bien le club
il faudra malaisie
[Applaudissements]
non mais je veux bien mené qui a fait le
coq est alors rachida dati vous qu'il
sait faire un animal
bon ben je sais faire la pie qui chante
à la baisse nous espérons nous et faire
la paix qui sort
[Rires]
on s'apprête à l'amant contre toute
attente c'est très bien faire la chatte
n'avoir jamais vu ça doit vous attendez
c'est alors là je ferme les yeux parce
que là c'est la pelle et à la rive
d'accord alors vous faites l'achat non
japonais je suis le maître le mettre là
j'ai jamais je commence à peine mais
nous nous y voilà
la ville est miné il nomine ou est ce
que j'ai fait mais non je t'ai dit
d'arrêter de jouer au lot de len lye
nous lasse elle se frotte contrat gens
meurent c'est là c'est là c'est là que
l'imitation s'arrête